hello welcome to Sid Trek your Sci-Fi TV
and Movie Channel live live how are we
all doing
jents we're good good doing well that
figured out how to do something very
clever with his camera and um that's
gonna be a bucket of fun today I'm tell
you yes it
is I mean as Harris looks like he's got
like a Darth Vader silhouette helmet on
so it's like you
know and now he doesn't now he's power
te isting the Stargate Atlantis I'm
supporting Stargate as generally we want
Star oh yes but he has he's picked his
team mine does say Stargate Atlantis but
it's invisible
Inc okay there you go then well let's
not ruin the surprise because we're not
all think hey sci-fi Quest how you doing
hello fisheries fies and kitties is in
the house Gio in the Philippines SJ is
the
best we we we probably think so so
today's video anyway I've been watching
Stargate um Atlantis again and I comes
to the realization it's just that little
bit better than Stargate y one um for a
few reasons that I talked about in the
video but what before we get stuck into
it though what do you guys actually
think I know it's like picking your
favorite child let's be honest we
shouldn't but we
do what do you think have you Matt what
do you have a preference I do against
your
head I
do I love sg1 and I love
SGU and SGA for all very different
reasons I think I prefer SGA however
simply because we got more of a more
backstory and more I don't know we got
to see more of the Ancients and the
ancients for me like one of the best
things about
Stargate yeah I think I think so I think
so gahar says hello Fantastic 4 yes we
are fantastic I am Mr Fantastic and
storm is the Invisible
Woman Matt actually you do look a little
bit like the thing little bit I knew
that was coming in a nice way and and
that makes you the the the
womanizing even though stormy's name is
stormy which we probably should go with
that
so how about you Harris do you have a
preference if you like gning against
your head pick one damn it I showed up
with it on I came prepared for this
one it's SGA it's just too damn good it
took the formula perfected it and
obviously they changed it after the fact
and people weren't happy about it be
mostly because I think it was a pretty
perfected formula at that
point I I would agree with you that's
what that's what my argument was that
they take took what was great about
issue one they learned from their
mistakes and they perfected it um but
stormmy do you have a preference I do I
have a preference and an opinion my
preference is sg1 because there's a lot
more Amanda Tapping in sg1 than there is
any of the other series I'm just sorry
it's a fact try to prove me wrong but
Amanda Tapping became the leader in
Atlantis she did did got more screen
time
well there's 10 seasons of her in in sg1
we only got two
season one season SJ wasn't um so yeah
wouldn't you like Atlantis more because
when sg1 was cancelled we still got to
see
her see that that's just you know it's
extending her presence true but there
was more aand of tapping in sg1 in total
screen time than there was
Atlantis sorry just you know she was in
that episode with Rodney though in the
um puddle jump about to
Dr yeah she's underwear at one point
yeah so we got to see a lot more
undering true episode than I mean if
that's where we're going with this so
I'm just arguing for screen time I don't
know what you perves are putting up
forth but I'm just we're young men we
well we're not so young
I'm the holdest thing here I'm just
going for screen time you know fair
enough fair enough um before we get
stuck into I've I've put some statements
together that are designed to irritate
slightly and we're going to discuss and
I think it allows us to discuss all the
different um perspectives are talking
about but before we do you might notice
the little thing scrolling across the
bottom that says citrek do. co.uk your
Sci-Fi TV and movie website because
Matt's been working hard again and we I
have a
website we do indeed so um you guys
might not that that Matthew was bugging
you for your email addresses the other
day and this is because you actually do
have access to this website too and you
can also write stories so in theory all
four of us might be writing stories for
the website whenever I do a video um I'm
going to try to do a story to go with it
so there should be lots of stories going
on there every week four four three four
stories a week in theory if I can write
them all but then we're going to invite
in anybody else and also if you are a
sidetracker and you want to write
something that you want to go on the
website with your opinion about Stargate
or any other sci-fi you can send it to
our email address at s. trek1 gmail.com
I don't know why such a confirmated
email address is don't know I could get
the time I don't know it was a long time
ago now um and we can submit it for you
there is a contact form as well on the
website you could submit it there
if you're like be also awesome and we
would love you guys because I mean we
got comments sometimes that go on a bit
uh and I'm supposed to read them and I
don't um but you you guys share them all
they're long um but brilliant I always
sort of I try to read them but some
sometimes um but guys if you have an
opinion you can share it with us and we
will put it on the website so um yeah
that's our big news that we've now got a
website I can't believe this took two
years to get to it to be
honest but it took me all damn day
yesterday to write like three stories
takes ages but um but it's good fun and
it's really easy to work it's a really
easy website to use so yeah you'll be
getting plenty of that please go on
there sidre ck. co.uk damn it um I just
saw this there though I Becket died
today in the episode I watched Carson
Becka
guy um and I'm I'm up to that and then
and I think um uh oh I forgot the
leader's name oh what's her name what's
her name for the first three seasons
leer it's got my head
who star Atlantis the civilian
leader we just died you sure yeah she
just took an explosion to the face so we
died like three times in s
yeah yeah Weir thank you so but she is
De and is the there you go cite trek.
co.uk please go and check it out um
right so let's get stuck into
this here we go here's the
first um SGA had silly space vampire
villains that made the go look
positively sensible
disuss um they AR the most there's a lot
of going on with the with the wfe yeah
um that when you notice it and start
thinking about it it's really
distracting um what do you guys think
they of all of the villains were they
good out of all of the villains they're
probably the most terrifying yes because
they're they're not they're humanoid but
they're not human whereas the go world
were aliens inside humans so they looked
human and then the Ori they they look
human the replicat has towards the end
looked human yeah this is like one of
the only villains that doesn't look
human and genuinely looks scary and I
think is
a welcome change the drones are
scary the Drone dudes especially with
the masks on yeah they were those guys
were kind of yeah yeah um they all
looked like like as ripped as TK as well
yeah were massive so imagine one of them
bowling up to you she like I don't know
in the nightclub I don't know why you'd
be in a nightclub with a wfe but like
he's hitting on your
misses you go up to him and you're like
can you please stop and he just turns
around you're like sorry mate you carry
[Laughter]
[Music]
on and then he puts your their hand on
your shoulder and you're just like oh
here we go this is how it happens I
believe in your in your culture it's
customary to shake
hands
that wraith
humor I love
that oh that's gonna be at the end of
the video we're just gonna be doing that
for like 20 minutes yeah um how about
you Harris what do you think is a
villain were they good they're they're
probably my favorite villain in Stargate
generally uh I I understand why we call
them and people call them space vampires
but I never really thought of them that
way cuz they're more like human insects
they're they feel very like they're like
a parasite more than a vampire in a lot
of ways so they feel freaking terrifying
when you think about them that way bugs
hiss all the damn time so it's kind it
kind of makes sense in that aspect too
uh but they're they're spooky you
literally walk up to any single one of
them and be absolutely terrified where
the ghou do kind of have a benefit there
where mirand backun wasn't a ghou but
one might look like her but one might
look like a haor you know you're not
going to be scared at first and then
you're like oh maybe I should be scared
after a little bit but the ghou have the
advantage of they're going to scare the
living hell out of you every second
they're in your presence and that's
that's just a good villain and for them
to work as hard as some of them have
like Todd to try to be good to a
degree is and you see how hard he has to
work to even be like kind of good
partially like okay you're kind of
neutral not even good even
I think that just is inherently a great
villain it took that much just to even
get him kind of to equilibrium kind
of the difference is with with the gold
compared to The Wraith the gold are just
[__] for the sake of being [__]
like they don't they
don't they would fine living in their
swamp and then they decided oh I'm going
to take over this body and I'm going to
take over the Galaxy the difference with
The Wraith is they did they had to do
what they did to surv survive they
couldn't survive without feeding on
humans and that's why they took over the
Galaxy so they could Farm humans and
have a constant food supply that's what
makes them scary it's not because they
they want to do what they're doing it's
just an evolutionary thing
and yeah
they yeah they're not necessar evil but
that's one thing with all of the
villains M and none of them are evil
evil for evil sake they're all there's
all a reason why they're evil thing
go H how about you stormy what do you
think about the race as a villain ah you
know I thought they were the weakest you
know they were just you know um they
were kind of their Galactic vampiric
insectoid kind of things the you
know the the villain I thought was the
wor was the best villain was the orai
because I think the
Ori represented the worst of humanity
and the worst of humanity is pretty
shitty
the the the thing that the or if you put
it in modern
parlament you know at least here at
America I always kind of see Donald
Trump as the Ori you know with his
little redheaded book of Origins running
around you know the the you know the I I
I see all I don't know I just I think
humans are the bigger monsters in in
some cases and if you look back through
our history that's kind of the case and
I never felt that the uh the The Wraith
wrath are just being wraith you know
that we they're kind of have this hive
mind and so they were never kind of the
villain it seems like you know because
of their biology they never really had a
choice
to be something different you know even
so even if you look at Michael Michael
quickly succumbs to their biological
behavior and um well I don't I don't you
know Rob I don't know if if it was uh
free stuff or not because they gave away
everything they gave away their freedom
they gave away their uh ability to
self-determine their own Society they
gave away everything for
convenience you and um I me it reminds
me I don't get I don't want get too
political but Patriot Act here in the
United States I me you got to take your
flipflops off and have a x-ray to make
sure you're not ATT are you talking real
life or the TV shows stormy see you go
we're talking about the TV villains not
not real
life that's why I think the Ori are the
the are are the best villains because
they show the worst of us but do they
aren't the Asian they they show worst
human aspects of things the Ori is
that's a religious like zeelot aspect
that's not Humanity per
se aren't they all of the things
metaphors that reflect aspects ofy so I
know a few people in the
in the comments are sort of saying oh
come on politics but these things do
reflect real life they do they are
supposed to reflect certain things that
the writers are you know are saying you
know the Klingons and the Federation
back in the original Star Trek was about
the Cold War it's about politics um you
know so um you the Ori are generally the
least popular with Gat they're by far
the weakest villains I think because of
everything that was just laid out
i i i Lov I love the AO I thought the AO
were a mate that they really good I
thought they were better than the gold
yeah I loved marinaa
bararan I like them better than I like
the gold with the exception of Cliff
Simon b b
and I like them too but with with Bal I
think he was he was like the anti-g he
wasn't really um the typical gold so
it's lovable Rogue they like B the
ultimate lovable Rogue because he was
just so arrogant and so but but just so
just like a he doesn't mean
it that was amazing well would that make
him more like goul 2.0 or the anti-
would would Anubis or him be more like G
2.0 or anti- Gould because they're so
arrogant like that Anubis was the best
villain for me like which one's more G
like Super G like so so G that the ghl
was like you can't do that that's too I
feel like that's
B no ball ball was ah Anubis wanted to
take over to destroy everything for the
sake of destroying everything B wanted
to take over because he thought he was a
good leader he thought he could do it
properly which doesn't that feel like a
g though I feel like he just epitomizes
a g b was so arrogant he thought he
deserved to to rule he was just like
because I'm so much better than
everybody else I just why aren't I
already you should you should want me to
be in charge um it was almost like when
people fought against him like why I'm a
and that but that's the go World in
general they they they wanted to be
worshiped because they were just so
amazingly arant which is why they love
them B we've all got at least one mate
that's a bit like ball that you'd sort
of like oh he's at it again for God's
sake but you're still his
mate i' I've know I know my mate I know
my one who's who's a bit of a pain in
the ass and he's always getting us in
trouble and he's my ball um we've all
got one but um you are B I'm not ball
I'm I'm the guy that's planning I I
think stormy who who's our B then not
that he's arrogant but he's the one that
gets us into
trouble
um
stormy
you um but you love me
and um and I'm not sure who Harris is
but he's we've all got haris Bach Jr I'm
gonna
fight go going back to Bob's comment can
I have my space corn buttered
please got faction have been played even
[Music]
scary space corn butter ises it too much
yeah I I just think yeah I think it was
mainly because Cliff Simon is so amazing
but I I always thought apus was amazing
as well and he was just so brilliant
that um and I forgot the actor's name
but he was just amazing and he made the
character own why he kept coming back
wasn't really
supp thank you um and it was just
brilliant yeah um stormy we don't love
you we do love you stormmy we love
stormy
um anyway he is a lovable Rogue Sarah
yes he
is I just I just loved your ology that
the Ori were were Donald Trump and I'm
just there Imagining the Ori coming
through the gate going make the Galaxy
great again everyone's got a
t leave it
alone we will lose subscribers um going
to be a problem much longer anyway so
don't worry about it um so right the
next little statement that I've got for
us SJ only really got good when Ron and
Dex turned up
ah we were just literally talking about
rainbow Sun Franks yesterday I had to
remember the name after Matt said it uh
yeah I would disagree because because
wear literally dies like multiple times
obviously she doesn't die by the time
ronin's in there but like she's amazing
at the beginning uh which was a hard
thing to do because obviously y'all
watched it more in real time as it was
coming out but just watching it from
streaming nowadays was like like why'
they just hire the I don't remember the
actress's name but the blonde lady that
played her in the couple episodes of sg1
and then you get uh where as a different
human being in SGA I never did
understand that I it was the other one
the other actress she was I think in
Earth two is I think it was an NBC
show and did a wonderful job there and I
really it was I thought she would have
been a better choice instead of the
choice we ended up
with I kind of agree with you but I also
do like I don't remember her name off
the top of my head but I do like who we
got a lot
uh Whatchamacallit I I did see an
interview with the lady that was
originally going to do it you know why
they why they fired her technically or
asked her not to come back was because
she was one of the people that was like
in charge of Burning Man they're like
you're gonna spend all your time doing
hippie [__] we don't need you it was
like a like we could have used Hipp
asked too many
questions apparently but I don't know
how true that one is because surely you
should ask questions about your
character I've actually heard that
that's one of the reasons why um David
blue isn't massively
popular well because he asked too many
questions he too many questions he was
always um he was always going on the
writers got to a point where they were
getting irritated by
him all I can imagine is like a a a Dr
Rush type director just being like shut
up shut up go and sit down in the corner
and learn your lines um but um but he he
actually was talking about it in the
video um that he did the interview he
did on shuttle pod how he was always
sort of asking questions and he and I
and and I'm there going yeah I've been
told that's one of the reasons why they
couldn't stand
you yeah he kept asking Brad
about really really specific
things and Brad would and Brad wouldn't
tell him anything
yeah yeah I think he'd ask Brad where he
thinks what's gonna happen in season
three and Brad wouldn't say
anything he didn't know yes yes was the
best underrated what was very I love w i
i just I love Robert picardo I keep
bugging him to see if I can get him to
talk to me so I can get him on the
channel doesn't respond but I'm going to
keep going he was he was horrible and
for the for the first part of SGA he was
that horrible character but he really I
think SGA redeemed
him horrible horribly
perfect I just watched the one where the
um the replicators attack the city walie
and um O'Neal I like hiding under the
think I just love him I just I just love
him and uh we got a double episode of
Richard De Anderson which is just
perfection um but yeah
so the first season though most sci-fi
shows struggle in the first season they
have to find their feet there's
characters that aren't quite right and
they have to jig things up a little bit
I would actually argue that Stargate
elitist did it pretty much all the way
through every season they jig something
I've just got three we're getting rid of
we we've got rid of uh the doctor whose
name has now gone out my head I knew
five minutes ago Carter um and we we've
got um the new new head of surgery um
juel state was it J I always mix her up
and um yeah Dr Keller yeah Dr Keller um
who I adore and you know so they mix
things up again uh was the first season
of star Atlantis particularly weak I I
wouldn't say so it had one of the best
finales of the entire run The Siege part
one and then part two was season two I
think was fantastic there's run about
four episodes the end of season one has
run up to season two which was sort of
all connected there was an overarching
Story three three or four episodes it
were just phenomenal
um I mean I think that's the other thing
that you think about the finales is a
bit similar to starget sg1 season 2
finale in St in story idea but um how
they have to go got The Wraith ship and
blah blah um but I think I just think
they were the best ones I just thought
they were just brilliant finales yeah um
that's something that I liked about SGA
as well sg1 did it
more so towards the the later the later
part of their run um but SJ felt St
Atlantis felt less episodic and more um
like there was an
overarching like theme like there was a
threat and every episode although you
could argue some of them were Filler
episodes they all contributed to the
overall story whereas with with sg1
there are quite a few episodes where you
could just look at it and go they're f
episodes you don't have to watch them to
understand the entire
story I don't I can't I've been watching
SGA at the moment and I can't remember
any Filler
episodes there are there are there are
some that you would consider Filler
episodes but my argument is they they
all still in some way contribute to the
overarching story so they might not be
necessarily
um on that topic the entirety but at
some point during the episodes something
will happen which will lead into the
next episode and the next episode after
that we W there was there was plenty of
episodes where they wouldn't they
wouldn't link into any other episode you
could watch that episode and then watch
your next one and it wouldn't have any
bearing on the story I think the only
one that the only one I can remember
that did was when Hammond is introducing
the Stargate program to the French the
Brits and I think the Japan Chinese
Chinese un thing Senator Kenzie comes in
starts you know bullshitting and then uh
Thor comes in Supreme Commander I think
because that there was a lot of uh
storytelling there that was kind of
needed to you know launch off the other
episodes it was definitely one of those
filler shows that uh that you needed to
watch to figure out what's going on
later but that's the only one I can
think of is there any other ones there's
one with the president as well wasn't
there with sg1 where the president got
um briefed yeah he got his briefing that
was that was just a perfect filler
episode I thought that was just genius
but um I mean in sg1 you've got the
whole giant alien story line with um
Daniel's Grandad or Uncle I mean that
that that is entirety entirely a filler
it was a very good story I really
enjoyed it but we never saw anything
else for it ever again nowhere um the
KNX story line to be honest I would say
was a bit of a f though because we only
ever saw them once or twice after that
we never really saw them
again the the cool thing about sg1
fillers I feel like when they I mean
almost I wouldn't say honestly like a
solid third of the show might
technically classify as filler but each
and every single one of those episodes
typically follows like a really cool
concept either within science or within
film like the the president Kinsey
episode not president Kinsey pre
president episode where he's briefed
isn't like cool sci-fi concept but it's
a cool film concept within Universe uh
following someone that's very important
to all of our main cast but we don't get
to see often kind of deal where the
other like the Knox episode or Daniel's
great uncle or whatever it was those are
really just cool sci-fi Concepts that
they can delve in but like like SGA
uh the closest thing to a fill episode I
can think of is T popping in for that
one episode just to fight Ronin for half
of it but it still went somewhere it was
really
cool I just don't think though that the
the main reason why
Stargate SGA was did I thought it got
off I I think some of the episodes were
just phenomenal I don't think it was any
weaker than any others I did get a bit
better they fine- tuned it a little bit
but I mean some of theod like when um
Rodney got the shield that was some of
the funniest part of you know see get
thrown off the grid of the thing and oh
is this where you started and then you
know shephers I go no I shot him so that
was one of the funniest scenes I think
it was as funny as anything one that was
in like the second or third episode or
something um you know it was um I
thought the show go after to a really
good start and and it's because they
knew what they were doing by that point
you know they had five seven years sorry
of sg1 they knew what they were
doing and they didn't go too far off the
formula which they did in SGU notice we
haven't mentioned SGU much talking about
the best of the Stargate franchises but
we're gonna in a minute I love
SG um SG did not deserve more seasons
and had run its
course wait what what what what
did not deserve any more seasons it had
Runar
Universe um no Stargate Atlantis
oh oh no no it definitely deserves
season six G
yeah yes did did yes yeah
did it wasn't done was
it they the race story line is not
finished I know they were going they
were planning on finishing it with
starget Extinction
but there's still like so much more of
Pegasus that they can explore like the
Janai still exist they're still a threat
I mean they're kind of like thean
Alliance in the Milky Way except a
little bit more you know
nice every now and
then hey everyone I'm a farmer no I'm
not I'm a military man I'm going to take
out now
[Laughter]
I just I I've just always thought that
there was so much more SGA for us that
um you know you obviously SGU you know
got got cancelled and we we wanted more
of that but I think it's just as equally
disheartening and then you know like the
disappointment of St I mean people
always going about this disappointment
of SGU being left on the cliff anger SGA
was as well you know we never got the
movie We were supposed to get it just
makes me want to cry and I'm watching at
the moment I've just started the fourth
season and I know I've only got two left
and it just breaks my heart and because
I know it's not in a way it's not going
anywhere yeah well the thing is with sg1
and star and
SGA um they both
ended
in a satisfying way yeah it wasn't an it
wasn't the ending but it was an ending
and it was satisfying with
sg1 they knew I think they were they
weren't going to renew for season no
they no actually they wanted season 11
they thought they were GNA get season 11
but they weren't quite sure so that's
why they ended sg1 the way they
did with starget Atlantis they were
convinced they were having um they were
going to get season
six but I think it was probably kind of
luck that they ended it where they did
and it's kind
of they they they feated the the threat
that was present at that moment so that
that storyline was all wrapped up the
ongoing threat still still exists
obviously so that's why we need a season
six but it did tie up all
the the pressing loose ends I guess I
just got a quick question for you
because I I did ask this question to
Matt when he was asking for quiz
questions but who is the one actor I
think he's the only one that appeared in
the SG in the Stargate movie the 94
movie
and appeared in starget sg1 is a
different character oh so not Kowalski
not Kowalski is a different
character was his actor's last name
French
no well not the one I'm thinking about
anyway there might be more but you
thinking of Lucian Lucius yeah yeah so
Richard kind played at one of the
Stargate one from there there's one um
who was in sg1 as
well I can't remember his name he was a
very minor character he wasn't he wasn't
as big as same character wasn't it now
fretti was played by a different actor
because we've had him on the show frety
was played by a different actor in the
movie was paid by the guy that was in
um
uh Third Rock From the Sun I think it
was called yes and comedy show and then
he he did a couple of movies as well but
in that one he was played by um Brett
State who is has been on the show Brent
state who's been on the show um but yeah
that's a little bit of fun I just occur
to me the other day um right so French
Stewart that's the GU yeah different
yeah yeah so yeah can we agree then that
it needed more we wanted more from SJ
didn't we
100% yes but coming from it just I guess
on on that streaming perspective as well
I would never have known that if it
weren't for yall I wouldn't have known
starget Extinction was going to be a
thing honestly I knew Continuum and Arc
of Truth were a thing going into sg1 and
all that and I was like okay they're
going to finish with movies not knowing
that there were supposed to be a movie
after SGA it feels like it was wrapped
properly to a degree because they make
it back to Earth and they kind of it it
does kind of feel like they tucked their
tail between their legs in a way uh so
so it would be nice to go back and have
them finish all that WRA storyline it's
not like Voyager L that they were they
were sorry to interrup that they were
trying to get home they could get home
anytime they wanted yeah maybe not with
the Atlantis but they could get home
anytime they want they could they could
you know they had the the Galaxy there
was no threat they were they had to get
back to save and destroy the hive ship
obviously but them getting home wasn't a
wasn't the point was it they tried to
wrap it up like that like oh we got home
you could have come home anytime you
wanted like it it worked but it's a
surface level work the second you
mentioned an SGA like movie it my brain
just is like ah duh you know
uh but coming from it from such a like I
guess later years kind of thing it
didn't feel like it needed more where
SGU I guess does feel like it needs more
I guess if that makes sense where i' I'd
still probably like to see SGA yeah I'm
gonna be back in one second but we had a
comment a second ago asking a question
do not smirk I don't need a we I I heard
my wife shout me I can see you smirking
stor
me what's gonna
happen um very quietly just tapped the
door going Jamie I think she needs me
for something but what was the best of
the DVD movies was it Continuum or arat
truth because somebody did ask in the um
thing a second ago for for me it's
continu
Arc of Truth was very much season 10
part like season 10 B I guess it was
literally just a finale but I kind of
like it more for that in that sense
because it fits with the show like it
was meant to where Continuum feels like
a longer episode but it was meant to be
more than that and it just doesn't hit
the ball on the head or hit the nail on
the head like it
should I don't know I I see if I was
going to
pick right so I did I did pick I bought
I bought continum and I bought Arc of
Truth and I wanted to watch one of them
I didn't know which one to pick but then
I picked Continuum because I think it's
a better story yeah I I liked the Ori
storyline
but a magic box that makes them all kind
of like
remember the the good in the world
I don't know yeah B Bal is like the
greatest villain from Stargate ever
apart from
anus I don't Michael just works so well
at the end of the day I don't he's just
one of those people that you don't need
often and every time he comes around he
makes just the the biggest of waves and
you feel the ripples of those waves for
half a season after he comes around
I I I feel like they did really well
with him I uh someone just said a minute
ago just to think about SGA real fast
was like they ran out of ideas by the
end of it it felt like they were just
retreading new territory replicators The
Wraith had kind of gone stale to a
degree they'd gone stale until they
introduced
clones there could be another six
seasons of TV just about clones there I
mean there was only one of the best
Sci-Fi TV shows ever the Clone Wars
written about clones that like lasted
seven seasons
so I don't know well not not to get star
warsy but they could definitely play
around in that field a
lot yeah you're mute
oh I can't hear you
what the gopher's gone silent shut up
nothing happened I didn't forget to
unmute myself
um if I'm gonna watch either of those
films I will always watch Arc of
truth it's more it's more exciting it's
more interesting but I am with you Matt
the magic box that tells you see the
truth for one I would argue what's the
truth the truth's perspective you know
truth has perspectives and what's true
for me ain't true for you um I think in
reality it was a reprogramming device
and what it it was programmed with what
Merlin or mirin had put in the
box and then it was his truth doesn't
make it the truth it was just Merlin's
truth so what's going to happen is the a
are going to come back at some point
worshiping
Merlin there's going to be people with
funny funny Wizards hats and big beards
just running around that look like
stormy loads of little stormies running
around you Denny gandal is the second in
command oh okay so I saw that
episode of uh Always Sunny with he was
in the chess
tournament
that [__] was that funny the slobber
erupting out of his
mouth Danny D is the greatest actor
on he
sweating so good it was the best
recommendation ever so okay I'll go
watch it I was fetal it was so
funny so any
de I could start just crying laughing
right now just thinking about the the
the moment
the first vibration is the funniest
moment enti
Year good he loved it to me all right
next question yeah yes
Matthew were
overpowered something we're moving on
we're moving on the puddle jumpers were
overpowered and ridiculous I want one I
want one as well but come on they were
seriously overpowered I don't think they
were overpowered in the context of where
they were they were in
Atlantis Atlantis was overpowered but it
wasn't overpowered in the context of the
Galaxy with The Wraith I don't I
wouldn't say it's overpowered at all the
sg1 was not underpowered they were just
underdeveloped like they literally the
second they even knew of the existence
of uh uh a puddle jumper they should
have been reverse engineering the
technology as much as they could to put
it into
sg1 yeah we they they had gate ships in
sg1 the Jafar one one that
um or someone had hid in a bush or
something yeah and Hammond FLW
it
like if they were gonna I I I never
understood why they never reverse
engineered that or you know like started
developing something because of that or
just give them freaking
four-wheelers
something
every experiment is walking distance
like every mission is walking distance
just like God's sake um I just thought
they were seriously overpowered like
because there were supposed to be a
shuttle but then they've got the Drone
weapons on board and maybe it was the
Drone weapons that are overpowered
because you could take out anything with
those things but only so few people can
actually use them and or even fly the
thing you know yeah they were they were
awesome Zarah they were I just thought
they would really over and then they
cloak and then they had a time machine
one and then um you know they had that I
just thought they would they would back
but then they had that one episode where
they would take one was shot down by
somebody with a catapult basically it
wasn't a catapult but virtually um so
maybe they weren't as overpowered but
well they survived the deep water better
than Ocean
[Music]
Gate yeah they did they did is well it
leaked it leaked did Samantha Carter had
help in that one see and panties so
there you go yeah exactly gate ships
sorry puddle jumpers gous P jump is such
a clever name as well I'm gra Brad right
one day who thought of that because it's
genius such a clever name I hope it just
again like on the spot your argument
about the the the
drones of the P jumpers they could only
store
12 you look I did I just looked it up
because I'm like I I can't remember I
can't
remember yeah but they could only score
12 which evens out I guess that limit
you like big time yeah yeah you'd have
be
more you
got in space you have to hit someone
with you have two six shooters and you
that that's all your defense in Space
the vast wide openness of space good
thing they're drones I think uh Trey
bone has a has a good point is it me or
did they really never achieve their main
goal of getting Tech to defend Earth
well I think they never they maybe not
have gotten the tech that they wanted to
defend Earth they just kept wiping out
the enemies of Earth or would be enemies
they just kept it they expanded the
influence of power of Earth to the point
that there was really nobody left to
need the weapons to defend
Earths go to the Pegasus Galaxy and then
you know deal with all that crap and
then when they dealt with all that crap
well let's go SGU to figure out what
happened to the Ancients and go see
where this ship's going and wait that
gate went to a ship we're on a ship and
okay we're running out of air and so
yeah I mean it's just we never I don't
think you know in hammon's worldview we
never got the the weapons to defend
Earth we just kept pushing the boundary
of influence of Earth out to where we
just kind of run out of enemies well we
were Gods by the end of it yeah we
negotiated for our technology at the end
of the day more so than Adventure found
it but good but good point Trey good
point Trey very good point so uh next
sg1 had more interesting characters and
stories do you think the characters from
sg1 were more interesting than the ones
from
SGA I love them to death but no I don't
know if I say there were more
interesting but there are
more instances in sg1 than there are in
SGA simply just just because there was
more of
sg1 you're
right there there's more entanglements
of us you know learning to walk and then
you know learning to run nsg1 and by the
time we got to um atlantas a lot of that
you know had already been worked out but
in terms of characters
I think Rodney he got the actor got so
much more uh opportunity to play that
character to the hilt you know but I
think yeah you I think Matt's right it's
just because we had Kinsey we had the
political angle Kenzie Administration we
had the you know the ni we had all all
of the batches of of um yeah of
different people trying to pull the
strings on the program you know and so
because we were learning to walk with it
this wasn't something we uh you know we
dis discovered a new faster jet engine
you know or more powerful rocket this
was a whole different thing that came
with cultural and
scientific challenges to Earth and I
don't think that could be replicated
because we had it all sorted out the
time we went to Atlantis
Oru it it almost feels like the writers
like
the SGA characters more than they did
the sg1 characters even though I think
they liked the sg1 characters obviously
they gave us 10 seasons of them in a
couple
movies even later on there's like we
were talking about uh Filler episodes
earlier even later on in the seasons of
sg1 they're still filler and that's the
time where hey we know these characters
we want story lines with these
characters they didn't really continue
to give us that I don't know if that's
the easy formulaic quote unquote lazy
approach and we're like okay this is
what we're used to we're going to keep
with it but in SGA they they gave those
characters room to breathe and it was I
think way better for it does that make
sense well I think you know during uh
Battle Star Galactica you know they had
a couple Filler episodes and the reason
the executive director Moore said he did
those was because the buz budget
constraints for uh the Sci-Fi channel
were so horrendous
that's the only way that they could um
get the season done because they Sci-fi
channel had just so killed the budget
especially in the later years later so
I'm just I'm just wondering if that also
happen with uh
sg1 or or SGA or Universe because like
you know it's I
mean sgate Atlantis that was still a hit
and they canceled it it was it was
budget yeah it
was well according to Joe Flanigan and I
I agree with him he basically said the
SGA got cancelled simply because um they
wanted to do something different because
they thought it would have more impact
they wanted to do something new and
another series of SGA just
didn't didn't have the impacts they said
we're going to end SGA and we're gonna
have something new because they have
more impact and that would make more
money and that was as simple as that um
and it was an idiotic decision
completely idiotic they needed at least
two more seasons of SGA they should have
they I love star Universe like Star
Universe was great but I don't think
they should ever have cancelled star
Atlantis in favor of starget universe I
think they should have done what they
did with Stargate sg1 have Stargate so
it was like what
season seven when seven or eight over to
they just finished seven they were just
starting eight yeah when they when they
Atlantis we we still have two seasons of
sg1 whilst we're watching Stargate
Atlantis and then Stargate sg1 gets gets
[Music]
canned yeah yeah yeah yeah and
then and then we're still watching Star
Atlantis and then s1's can we've still
got so I think they should have at least
had may may maybe one
but or maybe two but at least one
definitely one if MJ wasn't skint I
think they'd have done
it should manage their money better that
that's more of an MGM problem than a
Stargate problem at the end of the day
though right why it all got canceled and
screwed up because that was kind of
their intention their intention was to
continue SGA and have SGU running like
SGA had done for sg1 correct yeah yeah
that was the idea okay to go back to the
the characters then I would argue that
um
the characters in sg1 SG Atlantis at
least and I don't I think they were both
quite formulaic they were both you know
we had the funny Commander we had the
you know the Ronin character was a bit
like te and we had you know these things
um and I just don't I don't think either
character development was better or
worse I just think they're both they're
just different in some ways and they're
similar in some ways and but to me
O'Neal Shephard Teel
Ronan they're just all just I don't
think any better or worse I just think
they're both all lovable and I just
thought they're brilliant and I don't
think he can think they're just a little
bit different um they did such a good
job though creating another set of
characters we could fall in love with
which is very rare you know we get the
characters like O'Neal and and you know
and Carter and Jackson that we so loved
and they did it again with SGA and then
they didn't with SGU at
all SGA they
did characters you actually cared about
third time so I agree with you I
wouldn't say they're necessarily better
I did kind of say that in the comments a
minute ago but they just had more room
to breathe in SGA uh the main characters
at least guest characters
do guest characters though like
recurring guests SGA had a couple really
good ones like Michael like we mentioned
earlier but sg1 had the best the best
recurring characters almost of any show
I think I might have ever
watched I see uh uh T Tony amandola pop
up anywhere I'm just like BR Tech I just
get I just get so excited for anything
you know uh and and that's with any of
those guests he's just great they're all
great of
California he wasn't
looking Matthew of
Dudley I don't
know you live in Dudley don't you no
don't you where'd you live I'd actually
answer that off off I'm from Dudley no
I'm not I don't live in
Dudley
um mayborn some affiliate marketing
William um yeah may I think if you're
about main characters there's I think
you can split them no bother if you're
talking about secondary characters sg1
kicks sga's ass they're such a brilliant
character that we fell in love with like
B like AIT like you know all these other
characters as well that just they were
just amazing and I don't think SGA had
any really Michael I quite like I love
Chia in that character I thought he's
great um
the name The Wraith Todd Todd was great
Todd Michael uh who's the Janai uh guy
that's the the is it COA Coya Coya was
really
good Coya was good but only every time I
watch that though I'm going Goonies I
just that's all I think about is The
Goonies yeah so yeah it's yeah it's I I
think that sg1 had just just a massive
long list of brilliant recurring
characters you could even say like Bigs
like Thor you know just like another
it's a it was a puppet but even that's a
recurring character was just BR well I'm
glad you said that because I was
thinking about the unas I mean they only
did a couple episodes of that but the
the unas is that we got like mult
multiple appearances of those were great
too literally any of those small
characters that sg1 put forward were
just yeah great yeah col meanie was
brilliant in that as well in SJ in SGU
in SJ sorry just fantastic as a
Janai right love him so much okay then
here they go here is controversial one
sg1 was
funnier I think sg1 had the funniest
episode of any sci-fi episode I've ever
seen
I just think it
did the one H Day episode the time
travel under 69 no never I not a big fan
of 1969 know that always comes up as
like top 10 opportunity you want about
window of opportunity I think I think
that is the
funniest episode of sci-fi ever I mean
that is a laugh out loud you you get lot
sci-fi they s like but you don't get a
lot of sci-fi episodes that they're
probably like uh G yeah I pause it while
I just sort of laughing your ass off
sort of thing um wi makes me laugh my
ass off every time I watch it it just
does and and I don't
think but was FDA
funny I I think SGA was funnier more
consistently oh
yeah um swing yeah so sg1 was funny in
parts largely due to Jack
O'Neal um but I
think a lot of them in SGA were funny
Shephard was funny Rodney was funny when
he
didn't it was Shephard bouncing off
Shephard Ron and and um Rodney bouncing
off each other was always hilarious even
Taylor and
Shephard's quite funny in certain
certain
scenarios I yeah I just think SJ was
funny of more Rodney and Becket Rodney
and zelinka I mean they just had it was
great yeah Rodney was that you would
punch Rodney but I loved
him shepher in the same way you wouldn't
punch him necessarily but he's he would
be just as funny like and have those
same ancillary characters to go jump
back and forth
to just watch the one with the um yes
Rodney I shot you and I said I'm
sorry just so funny shot me as well I'm
sorry I shot it
every it's just brilliant so but like
said with the shields with the human
shield pushed off I shot him first they
were like I remember that I've got two
brothers and we used to just pick on
each other constantly but I just imagine
that's what it was that's they're like
family just bullying each other and they
they don't act like they like each other
very
much what say there there's a a video on
YouTube it's it's called like Space
Goofs or something like that
it's dedicated to them too it's really
good
yeah um I I i' also love like Ronin
though when you know they did the
episode when um Rodney got superpowers
and he starts going stealing people
donuts and things he got and um and he
says to the doctor and that you couldn't
stop me from leaving anyway and Rona
because I can I goes oh yeah okay yeah
inite back and then you can be my uh you
can be my back you can be my um uh we
can be like Batman and Ronin and be more
like fat man and Ronan you keep
e just they're just brilliant they're
constantly you know on it each other and
I just like Ronan particularly was
really funny just with they like I I
don't want it in the background it be
like that little comment at the end of
some much's going on and R like and it's
just just funny they feel more familial
in that way where I understand sg1 is
such a family but it's that the I think
the difference was
everyone on Atlantis kind of got to
choose if they were going to be on
Atlantis so they were like okay well now
we got to find friends we've got to find
people that we can we can hang out with
that we'll enjoy where sg1 they're
literally all forced to be there in a
way the only one that's choosing to be
there's tilk by technicality so they do
learn to love each other over time and
they are a family by the end of it but
it's it's Rocky every now and then it
takes a little bit
where chosen family they're trapped on
Atlantis they have to love each other
it's Stockholm
syndrome
okay yeah they all have to love we
because she's she's captured them um but
yeah I I just yeah no I I actually think
even though sg1 had the funniest episode
um SGA was funny I think SGA was
consistently funny and and and I keep
saying to you guys as well like like
when you see gritty dramas and they're
not funny I think that's not very
realistic because gen speaking I know of
me the more stressful a situation the
more stupid the humor gets and that's
why I thought anal was actually so
realistic because you do crack stupid
jokes when you're you know when you're
stressed and when you're scared and when
you you know and and they did the same
in SGA and I just thought I
just I'm thinking the the the the
reasons why even to this day Firefly is
beloved by everybody because it was an
action show with lots of really
well-written humor and the actor just
really
delivered you
know yeah and yeah and I say but it was
natural humor it wasn't jokes sort thing
humor um I could see somebody going like
that that you shot me thing you shot me
I'm sorry that's that was I could so see
that you know like soldiers or something
and the soldier accidentally Clips one
like God damn it you shot me man and he
like look I'm sorry he said I'm sorry I
could so see people saying it and that's
why I think that's why it's so funny
because it was written so believably
sort thing um right it's the last one
and we're hitting an hour I promise my
wife I'd be off by half seven so um the
last one SGU was better than both anyway
s sit
[Music]
on I I can't agree with this one because
it
wasn't some people genuinely think
starget universe is not just the best of
the Stargate they think it's the best
sci-fi show ever made and and I'm not
going to tell anybody their opinions
wrong except for this one because but no
I'm not gonna tell no one's opinion is
wrong on this universe is good if you
like
Stargate it's Stargate and it's good it
was whatever you think about season one
season two was great and it was getting
really good and then they ended it
whatever but it is not better than
Stargate Atlantis no way as a massive
Stargate Universe fan it was it was not
it was not it never had a chance to get
its legs you know yeah and maybe it
would have done eventually but yeah what
we got I mean it was such a foreign
concept to what we know as uh you know
Stargate you know always uh you know a
tightly run military organization
fighting evil and here we got you know
the the commander was uh an alcoholic on
sugu the and he I think got the Nur the
the nurse pregnant and it was not a
tightly run military organization it was
kind of Civilian and then they had the
stones and go back and forth and then
there was some Dianes on the side not a
tightly run military
organization and so it was really
chaotic and they hadn't had I don't
think they had an opportunity to uh
build the the the show around that kind
of chaos I think I'm right in thinking
Brad Wright talked about um his biggest
regret from Stargate was the stones that
he thought it was just a stupid
technology but if people talk about the
Zach being stupid technology you know
the um the the the the space dildo um
Stones were stupid and it's just just
boring and lazy and I hated the stones I
don't know if they're stupid they just
they they made them stupid by overusing
them so much so quickly that first
episode was jarring just because of how
much they were with the stones you know
you're thinking I'm going to be in space
this entire time and you're on earth
with like somebody as somebody else with
their wife and you're just like what
what what's going on I I I see what that
comment might be saying like
SGU could be the best sci-fi show ever
written it it conceptually possibly if
it was allowed to
continue uh but it didn't get there it
wasn't on it was it was just maybe
getting on its way there I guess and it
and we we'll never know if it were going
to be if it was going to be grammar I
don't think it could oh sorry SGA was SG
was ahead of its time I actually think
that's probably not wrong in some ways I
think it probably was it felt like a
streaming show I wonder you would have
been better if it was 10 episodes more
impactful um bit more money spent on
each episode even though it had a lot of
money spent on it um and maybe it would
I think SGU might have been less is more
maybe yeah um because it was boring it
was so boring the first season Matt I
mean honestly mate I watched the first
season and I slipped into a coma for
three
months I had atopy I really I really
love the SGU I couldn't wait for the
next episode because I like the the
father son antagonistic relationship of
Eli and Rush well the relationship of
everybody in rush but specifically Eli
in Rush how he's being pulled toward you
know a mentor type like Rush against the
uh the the uh Colonels kind
of leadership so so to speak yeah yeah I
I I really respected Rush as as a
character but he was boring um tal
Phillips was
boring um uh the the the colonel whose
name off has got out my head like it's
like Shepherd isn't it but it's not
Shepherd young
boring um a lot of the background
character characters they never
developed um it was just the first
season it was but it was getting better
and like I said loads of sci-fi shows
are not great at first SGU actually the
first three episodes of SGU were were
actually really good and the four then
the third episode was when it
went um it got
boring it's just it's just
boring and I just there's no humor to it
there's no fun to it Eli's literally
making humorous comments every minutes
in that show funny they weren't
funny the one remember in like the
second episode and he's going oh you
destroyed it you crazy fool something
and he like doing a bit of a um Planet
the Apes joke wasn't funny I was about
to say do not like movies because he
just was literally making Spider-Man
jokes the entire time and I loved it
every single time he's literally just
making pop culture jokes I would say
he's making pop culture references I
don't think they were jokes because it
just didn't tick on my you know how is
that different than someone in a bad
situation in war saying you you shot me
you know like making a funny comment out
of a bad situation I guess comedy is um
obviously very subjective that it just
didn't work for me you know it's just
like a different comedian I just didn't
get it um that's because you were in a
coma for three months and it was
canceled when you woke up because I fell
asleep I kept nodding
off have they won yet there a bad guys
won yet what what happened and in
credits again damnn it um I you know no
I I look and I'm I'm I'm only comparing
this though to sg1 and SGA s is still
better than 90% of the Sci-Fi out there
and it's still Stargate and I would
actually put it up against and Star Trek
any Star Trek series and it's still
brilliant and I still love it but
compared to sg1 and SGA it was boring it
was up its own ass it was way too
serious um and I
actually conceptually didn't think it
was a very good idea see who was it um
in the comments uh that was oh yeah uh
track gate he said you the worst moment
in SGU was rush and young fighting and
leaving Rush stranded I thought that was
the best [__] ever you know uh young
being so sick of Russia's [__] well
you're just staying here dumbass and he
just leaves him on the planet I thought
it was just wonderful you know and then
he comes back no idea what to do yeah
it's I thought it was great I literally
I I young is one of those people that
like those that first season when I was
watching I was just like I I I I was
kind of with you Jamie I was like this
guy's boring this guy's like kind of
like what's going on with them but by
the time the Rush episode happened and
you just kind of continue that character
development I I haven't loved to hate
somebody that much since like Darth Maul
like I I just I it was so much fun to
hate
Colonel young uh where Telford was kind
of a boring character super well acted L
Diamond Phillips is one of my favorite
actors love guy perfectly acted but the
character was boring because it relied
on young until it got to season two and
then damn damn keep it
coming I I it was getting better in
season two the drama was more
interesting it was still boring but the
drama was way more interesting and it
was dramatic that's what I think I think
sg1 and SGA were
entertaining SGU was a serious
television show it was it was dramatic
it
was more interesting in lots of ways
because a lot of the stories that were
going on and some of the development
stuff that was going on but I mean look
we're talking about it and Matt started
yawning because it was so boring so I
mean he's ready to KN off
now because boring and and that's that's
the only thing for me it was it was it
was difficult to watch at times it was
you were you were skipping a lot of
episodes if you I've seen that one
before don't come else that obviously
they were trying to do something very
different so yeah and and I I think it
heralded in a new era of Television
whether it was the end of an old one and
and bring it in like literally Game of
Thrones feels like SGU in some ways the
expanse feels like SGU ahead of its time
definitely I I I just I don't know I
wish we were allowed to do something
more um I just think 10 episodes on a
streaming service that show would have
got easily Seven Seasons easily easily
yeah yeah it was because it was and I
think it would have been better because
I like like I said I think it would have
been more focused I think it would have
been more a little bit more boiled down
um they wouldn't have had to try to fill
quite so much time and they could have I
think it would have been a much better
show for it I think less would have been
much much more with SGU if it had
switched over it's almost like if they'd
have done two more seasons of Atlantis
and then done SGU on Netflix because
that would the timing would have been
better would have been about right for
it we'd have got a better show oh Big D
you know that's just but I I might be
wrong but I mean that's that's how I
feel it's a
shame I I think you're perfectly right
hindsight is 2020 and that sounds about
right like would have been nice anyway
that's our thing so just to think I
think we all agree then other than
stormy who is incorrect and this one the
SGA was just s a little bit better than
sg1 they perfected it
and if you watch them now I just think
it's a little bit more
watchable um for
me lack of Amanda Tapping but watch them
all it's not SGA versus S versus sg1
this is this is all a big family this
is four of us yeah the four of us we're
just bitching about you know really
really minutia fine points of three
different shows and a couple of TV
movies that were all really well done
you know we're in minutia I mean you
know Infinity what are you talking about
Matt
Infinity five then in that case
Origins that was another movie though
origin is a web series
yeah but then they compiled it to a
movie yeah yeah okay that's the best way
to watch it yeah it is my far the best
way I will quote the great gopher above
me right quick from from a shuttle pod
uh podcast or Shuttle pod show uh or not
when you were interviewing the shuttle
pod show because when you'all talking uh
Star Trek and you you said the only
reason I'm like talking so nitpicky is
because I absolutely adore like each and
every single one of these shows and
every single episode yada yada and
that's why I like to get nitpicky about
it that's what we're doing that's what
we're doing star because I love it so
much if I didn't love it I care we just
EXC talk about star that's all it is
yeah it's just an excuse talk about star
that's why I get I get really annoyed
with people that go stop being so
negative about Star Trek I'm like no I'm
negative about it because I love it and
I'm disappointed if I didn't love it I
wouldn't care so I mean I wouldn't be
talking about it but um but yeah this
was just this was just a you know your
two your three favorite kids and you got
to pick one um that's that scenario and
just would it in realistically would the
favorite kid ever be the middle
kid I'm the middle child calm
down let's step away from that comment
I'm no yeah no wasn't my little we have
all been Weir Stockholm Stockholm
syndrome on atlan with uh Jamie here
it's yeah my mom's not my mom doesn't
even try to hide the fact that my little
brother's her
favorite it at all she'll quiet say no
he's she she says he's my baby and that
like that justifies it stop favoring
him
mom anyway uh this is gonna turn into a
counseling session if we not careful I
full-blown syndrome in lots of ways so
yeah that's that that's we done Stargate
was amazing we love all Stargate um and
that's and the conversation so before we
go we've got about 10 minutes so we've
got about and then we've got probably
four or five minutes whatever stormy
thinks up at the end to annoy me with
I've got to be off by half seven though
so don't mess with me today stormy I'm
telling you don't mess with me um my
wife is already gone you won't be and
I'm like no I will I will so what we've
been watching this week guys um if you
talk about a shoker though I'm going to
bed
last night I'm still watching Walking
Dead I'm on season seven I'm absolutely
loving it Negan
is a good character wonderfully horrible
I
love love the just sliced open well
there's a couple of episodes go now he
sliced open the belly of uh a particular
person I'm not going to spoil it for
anyone who hasn't seen it but it rhymes
with benser and
he just one the best lines ever and it
was you got no guts and then he goes oh
silly me they were inside you the whole
time how wrong was I he brilliant
when that that's when that series got
really really good it got freaky good
when that was him um how about what you
guys what you guys watching at the
moment yes
please uh let's see the
since I've been moving these last couple
weeks the only thing I've really had an
opportunity to watch is the last three
episodes of foundation plowed through
those last night and it continues to be
really good uh poor [__] Harry Seldon
always is
just man he can't catch a break yeah you
know I've got one episode to watch so
don't ruin it but I got one left I've
got two Foundation One Silo to watch I
forgot Foundation I I I I literally
yesterday while I was just like
chronically awake still I was like I
need to watch like a show what should I
watch real quick I couldn't think of a
single thing I was like I know there's
something that I'm watching right now
that a new episode's out and I haven't
seen it I watch the first two episodes
of the season of foundation I gotta
catch up damn I want to watch I can't
wait to watch Invasion season two's just
come out first season was so good uh Sam
Neil stars in it as well and I'll tell
you
what people hate Apple I don't quite
know why I know they hate the company
they hate their business practice they
that sort thing but apple plus is the
best um Channel or streaming service if
you like sci-fi it's just just brilliant
everything's well done everything's very
well done um they got this show as well
that sort of skipped Me by um what's it
called um in not I want to call it I
want to say it's called attack or
something it's not that's not right um
another alien another alien inv show and
there's these like things at spes and
it's just phenomenal that's as
well I'll find it talk
yourself Ser I'm gonna google this and
find I'll give you a Futurama update I
was pissed off the first couple episodes
because you know I I I wanted to be the
Sci-Fi show that I I'm I'm trying to
hopefully Herald it in as and the first
two episodes of this season the new
season could have just been a Simpsons
episode it was like all right this is
just another Simpsons episode it's not
it's with the Futurama people but it it
doesn't feel like what it should feel
like they kind of got back to sci-fi in
the last week so I'm happy about that
I'm hoping it continues but only murders
in the building is great right now I
don't know if y'all are familiar with
that Martin St Steve
martinz New Seasons freaking excellent I
was worried about it but it is so good
run Merl
Streep uh and then what we do in the
shadows is hilarious as always I don't
know if youall know that but funny
vampire stuff is great the black and
white looks beautifully terrifying
Matt I think it's just Invasion I'm
talking about actually sounds
like invasion's great um yeah I haven't
watched any futur armor and I haven't
watched any of um thing in the buildings
yet it's crap M I'm not watching it and
I don't watch The Simpsons anymore
anymore either for the
same um it's it's not it's not crap but
I've just I've just watched them all
this night no
um what have I been watching I've just
watching starget
Atlantis I'm on season I'm just starting
I'm just kicking into season four and
I'm just loving it I've forgotten it's
like watching it all again because it's
been so long since I watched it it's
like watching it all new so just great
I'm I'm remembering the odd episode here
and there but there's so many episodes
I've forgotten all about it's just I
just love it so I'm just watching that
and um about a rewatch is remembering
all the old episodes that you just for
some reason forget forgotten all about
or you know I remember I vaguely
remember what happens but I'm like I
can't remember how they get there so
it's like oh it's just it's just great
love it so that's all I'm watching
moment just I always love that episode
where there was essentially another
Atlantis which was overgrown with weeds
and all like trees and that it was I
think it was called the tower I'm sure
that's what the episode was called and
it was essentially another city ship but
this man just took it took it over as
king Yeah just they never did anything
else with that
though and the replicators had a couple
atlantes and they were just kind of
let's blow them up you think how many
other Atlantis are there in the Pegasus
that they don't know about yeah exactly
I did watch the first episode of a
shoker um Harris because you told me
to wasted that was a waste of my time
how so I didn't know what the hell was
going on
is that
really um and and and honestly and and
the bit that I did understand I didn't
care about and that might be because I
don't like Star Wars
possibly I know be um but I I try to
watch it it's
just I struggle with Mandalorian and I
actually enjoy Mandalorian and I
struggle with that it's it was so slow
does it does it pick up at any point
what Mando or Ahsoka ahoka I mean
there's only one one other episode so
far and yeah it picked up oh God so um
if I watch it again and it's crap do I
get to punch you in the
nuts um if you can reach that far across
the pond sure Coming to America next
year and when I come to America next
year I if I if a Soaker is rubbish I get
to punch you in the nuts he's gonna come
at you like this
uh I I think this coupon will expire
within two months um I will pay for that
damn ticket he's fly all the way out
here that would be F drive over punch
nuts go get on the plane I'll be back at
work Monday morning no bother
um two full days of travel do the
weekend Jay oh I went to America to
punish you do anything else
no yeah
travel I'm very
jetlagged food yeah you wouldn't get
jetlagged though would you it's like a
hour flight punch him in the nuts go
back eight hour flight that's a day
that's like 20 hour day it's a 20 hour
day it's a long day
but yeah I wouldn't want to do that
Journey um hope
not the chat well which P the me
punching Harr and the
nuts what have I said now that I'm not
going to want to
forget I sometimes I forget what I said
um but yeah cool um I I'll pull a stormy
real quick oh boy don't know if y'all
watched it ever but I know stormy
watched a little bit and really enjoyed
it have you seen the new season of solar
opposites
no you remember solar oos right stormy
the the alien animated or TV show from
Mor yes yes oh I do know what you're on
about yeah I do know what you're about
because the Rick and Morty guy that the
voice actor that just not a very good
human being uh he got replaced by Dan
Stevens the British dude and it's like
the first episode's super freaking
jarring but it is the funniest thing
ever and I I think it might be my
favorite season so far they literally it
doesn't spoil anything but literally
within the first 20 seconds of this new
season they slit the alien's throat open
the main guy that was voiced by Justin
royland and they're like we're a Sci-Fi
show fix it with the voice like fixing
Ray and they just shoot him they make
his voice British and they're like we're
keeping it it's gonna stay and that's
how they do it and it's so great s Quest
got so dark so quick there it did it did
so dark so
fast right
guys thank you so so much been a
brilliant chot as always we've covered
lots of
areas including some areas which which
we hadn't but we got there so next week
we'll be back I don't know what we're
talking about yet but we will um
everybody go and check out the website
because that was basically my entire day
yesterday writing those and if the
grammar's not very good I don't care
leave your comments to yourself I've got
dyslexia so leave me alone um and it's
Matt's fault anyway because he's
supposed to proof fre so um which is no
no no I gave you a login so you could do
it
yourself you posted them yourself can
can you prove also tell you you can
schedule posts so I'll let I'll show you
how to do that I need to do that
actually because I've got one tomorrow
then I'm gonna write in the morning but
need to schedule for after I no you
posted like five all at once yeah I know
um but I won't be I was I was catching
up so but now I won't be now
I'll on yeah I need to write it in the
morning for it to come out in the
evening so I'll do that would you would
it be proper to have butt plug reviews
on the new website you can go for it
yeah go for it me you can do whatever
you
want let him do it mate if he wants to
do it but they will have to be sci-fi
related butt plugs I about to say we
should start a line of merchandise here
um
no no thank
you who's GNA be the model for that is
it
you
oh I'll be the model why not Danny Gand
has volunteered
himself the wise owl he's
here I've had we were talking about this
yesterday I've um we've started to get
some emails from like sponsors to try
and get to sponsor shows right none of
them are B butt plug but one of them was
Teemu or something website and I'm not
I'm not a fan so we're not going to be
pursuing that um but they do sell things
like that and um their was that we could
spend $100 and like we could like get
some clothes and stuff from them and
then you know you can ab and I'm like
how am I supposed to slip that into it
oh by the way we're talking about
starting talk about star look what I got
from Teemu and I don't know how I could
slip it in um but um and it's not a very
good website from what I can see but
um they do sell things like that well
you know which one of us has the most
marketable uh butt plug um name or
nickname or anything of the sort as of
as of yet
right probably uh no I think the great
gopher himself what go what do gophers
do I couldn't I couldn't get a butt plug
up there I'm too I'm too clenched I'm
English that's all right I've got a big
hammer
Mallet why do this
why
WHYY comes along with his hammer on J's
[Laughter]
like Mike R had a good idea stormy can
do the teu uh teu ad advertisements he
can just slip it
in why do we do this to
ourselves um puddle jumper butt
plug through the
gate for the
old brilliant in so many wrong ways
great gopher's puddle jumper It's Hammer
Platinum
Edition be great all right we're
done so thank you so wife on the other
side of that door what are they talking
about this yeah my wife's Gonna Be
Wondering but anyway we are out here no
more stop it so oh
guys have a lovely week everybody in the
comments thank you so much again for
joining us you've been amazing as always
and also you can have a lovely week too
if you'd like um I'm back to work on
Tuesday after two weeks off
so I'm probably gonna do a live on
Wednesday and it'll be me crying because
I'm back to work and post holiday Blues
so come and join us for that no idea
what I'm be talking about but I'll be
live on
Wednesday guys thank you so
much thank you by guys thank you for
coming by everybody byebye everybody
[Music]
ad haris was still
alive I'm just wondering what you're
gonna do next
mate it's supposed to be
brief I I decided this last week I was
gonna hold on
is this a bad time to start talking
about the [__] rings of
chock goodbye
goodbye